et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
aujourd'hui marc semo du journal le
monde bonjour marc bonjour face à vous
virginie herz chroniqueuse international
présentatrice d'actuels chaque semaine
sur france 24 bonjour virginie la russie
at-elle commis l'irréparable
à la veille de négociations à antalya
sous médiation turque les premières à un
tel niveau on va y revenir
l'ukraine accuse l'armée russe d'avoir
détruit une maternité preuve à l'appui
avec ses images de la ville assiégée de
marioupol et cette déclaration écoutez
dès cette date il s'agit de la troisième
clinique est détruite par les russes
ils ont déjà bombardé le centre médical
où l'on soignait les malades du cosy d'
c'était un hôpital avec 600 lits
ils ont aussi frappé le centre de
collecte du sang de mario paul
les gens vivent depuis vit jour sous les
bombardements incessants
nous pensons qu'il ya déjà eu environ
1200 or
nous ne pouvons pas les enterrer dans
des tombes individuelles
nous sommes obligés de mettre les corps
dans des fosses communes la plupart des
habitants veulent partir
cela fait déjà cinq jours que l'on
essaye de mettre en place des couloirs
humanitaires pour acheminer de l'aide
vers marioupol et évacuer les habitants
de la ville
mais c'est impossible avec ces
bombardements permanent
selon nos estimations il y encore quatre
cent mille civils à marioupol
cela fait huit jours que nous n'avons ni
eau ni chauffage ni système sanitaire
les russes ont bombardé une pipe lines
qui nous approvisionner en gaz nous
n'avons plus rien
nous ramassons de la neige pour obtenir
de l'eau voilà la situation réelle à
marioupol en ce moment
avec le bombardement de cette maternité
un point de non retour at il été
franchie marc semo mois une retour je ne
sais pas mais ce que l'on voit là à
marioupol c'est ce qu'on avait vu alep
en syrie c'est une technique éprouvée de
par des russes qui bombarde et alep qui
est celle de viser aussi des hôpitaux
voire principalement les hôpitaux les
cliniques pour évidemment inciter les
gens à fuir marioupol est un objectif
stratégique fondamental dans cette
offensive rousse d'autant qu'elles
piétinent un peu partout et marioupol
c'est la mer d'azov c'est la continuité
territoriale entre le dôme bave ces
républiques autoproclamées reconnu par
poutine et la crime est donc un objectif
fondamental des villes autour sont
tombés vers jiangxi et c'est donc là les
russes feront tout pour vider marioupol
d'où ces attaques contre les hôpitaux
d'autant plus qu'un cessez-le-feu était
censée concerner précisément cette zone
de mario paul pour permettre l'ouverture
de couloirs humanitaires virginie et là
aussi on a une impression de déjà vu en
fait cette histoire de couloirs
humanitaires en syrie notamment à un
moment donné ça il ya des cessez-le-feu
enfin des trêves qui sont qui sont
négociés finalement ça marche ça marche
pas ça marche très mal et on
al'impression effectivement que tout est
fait pour démoraliser la population des
civils sont visés plus ou moins en tout
cas des institutions des organisations
civiles son délire et moi il s'agit pas
de bellevue libéré mans en tout cas au
point que notamment l'allemagne la
justice allemande et la justice
espagnole ont décidé d'ouvrir des
enquêtes pour crimes de guerre comme la
cour pénale internationale
pour le moment on n'a pas une vision
extrêmement clair mais effectivement des
enquêtes vont être ouverts en raison
aussi donc d' attaques sur ses hôpitaux
ses zones résidentielles de des largages
de bombes à sous-munitions aussi
interdire par les consciences nationales
parce qu'elle reste aussi durablement à
portée de civils qu'ils peuvent des
années plus tard même en être victimes
et notamment des enfants parce que ce
soit en serre sans mettre des petites
billes est déjoué quasiment donc on est
sur le même phénomène que des mines
antipersonnel et voilà est donc en tout
cas tout ça fait que effectivement on a
l'impression d'un scénario que d'un
scénario qui a été déjà utilisée à
plusieurs reprises et notamment
notamment pour la première fois la
russie en tout cas elle reconnaît à la
présence de conscrits en ukraine c'est
le porte parole du ministère de la
défense qu'il a admis écoute et
sensuelle malheureusement plusieurs cas
de présence de conscrits dans les unités
des forces armées russes participant à
l'opération militaire ciel sur le
territoire de l'ukraine ont été
confirmés presque tous ces militaires
ont déjà été retirés sur le territoire
de russie vladimir poutine avait
pourtant assuré ces derniers jours ne
pas faire appel aux conscrits nous ne
pas même en avoir l'intention celle ci
n'a que l'offensive s'avère plus
compliqué que prévu pour moscou marque
disons ce qu'on a l'impression c'est que
mr aussi mais énormément de temps à
obtenir un certain nombre de ses buts de
guerre kiev globalement le siège n'a
même pas encore réellement commencé avec
toujours cette colonne bloqué au nord
bon les laisser sur l'est les
les offensives piétine karkhiv pareil et
yako sud où justement il ya cette
remontée d'où cet enjeu de mario palme
il est évident que par rapport à ce à
quoi s'attendait
l'alarmé rust tout est changé il ya une
réelle résistance de la part des deux
ukrainiens et on voit une armée russe
qui rappelle celle de grozny en 1990 mal
préparé mal motivée mal commandé et ne
sachant pas ce qu'elle fait là et à
propos et à propos de ces soldats de ces
jeunes soldats dont certains sont morts
ont été arrêtés ou comme ça ça peut
jouer aussi un rôle dans le moral de la
population en russie notamment je pense
aux maires des soldats russes qui une
association donc qui avait été créée en
1989 qui avait obtenu aussi des
informations au moment de la guerre de
tchétchénie sur ses envies enfin sur ses
enfants sur ces soldats qui avaient été
envoyés au front dont on n'avait pas
d'informations qui étaient elles mêmes
sur place pour aller récupérer leurs
enfants aujourd'hui elles ont du mal à
s'exprimer pour le moment parce que les
nouvelles lois sur la liberté
d'expression ont été extrêmement
resserré donc elle ne parle pas encore
mais il commence à y avoir des
mouvements il ya une vidéo que notamment
qui circulent sur le gouverneur de
sibérie qui est interpellé au cours
d'une réunion publique par une de ces
mères justement sur le sort de ces
soldats qui ont été envoyés au front
alors qu'on leur disait que c'était une
opération spéciale ou peut-être juste
une petite intervention voire même une
manoeuvre juste un point là dessus les
ukrainiens ont été extrêmement habile
parce que les prisonniers peuvent
téléphoner à leur mère on a vu des
vidéos des donc les informer et les a
formés et ont dit aux mères qu'elles
peuvent venir chercher leurs enfants
donc c'est en termes de déco et de voilà
deux ans alors que le système de la
formation totalement verrouillé sur
cette opération en russie il ya
justement par en dessous par les
sociétés civiles des choses qui
commencent à circuler ça pourrait
conduire la russie à négocier plutôt
prévue aujourd'hui la porte-parole de la
diplomatie russe à maria zakharova
assuré que moscou ne cherche pas à
renverser le gouvernement ukrainien
contrairement à ce qu'avait affirmé des
responsables russes depuis deux semaines
virginis ainsi l'ouverture ça alors on a
l'impression que à un moment donné ou
juste la cacophonie à un moment donné
ils bavent il va falloir négocier la
question c'est quand est-ce que ça va
être maintenant ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'on en parlera peut-être un peu plus
tard il va ya voir l'ouverture de faire
cette rencontre entre les ministres des
affaires étrangères russe et ukrainien
en turquie maintenant pour le moment les
objectifs russes et de vladimir poutine
sont toujours les mêmes à savoir la
délimite démilitarisation de l'ukraine
la garantie que l'ukraine n'entre pas
dans le temps là dessus le président
zelensky a dit qu'il avait peut-être un
petit peu changé et évolué nenê insisté
peut-être plus trop là dessus en
revanche sur la reconnaissance de la
crimée enfin la reconnaissance que la
crimée l'annexion de la crimée plus
l'autonomie totale pour les républiques
du nom de basse là dessus pour l'instant
le président des nets ce qui a dit que
c'était pas négociable sur une
définition de feu étaient prêts à
négocier mais pas capituler ça nous
amène évidemment la réunion de demain
donc à antalya sergueï lavrov face à son
homologue ukrainien dmitro coup les
bavettes co-médiateur le turc mevlüt
cavusoglu écouter le président turc à
tchita hyper douanes
j'espère que la première réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'ukraine et de la russie qui aura lieu
jeudi le couvrira les morte un cessez le
feu permanent auquel nous nous
félicitons également tout cessez le feu
annoncé pour l'évacuation des civils
avant cette réunion cruciale
notre pays va accueillir
[Musique]
comme refusant d'abandonner d'ukraine
nous n'acceptons pas non plus les
actions qui s'apparente à une chasse aux
sorcières pour le peuple les étudiants
ou les artistes russes
première rencontre un tel niveau depuis
les deux semaines maintenant que dure le
conflit ça peut déboucher sur quoi
maximum pour demain c'est difficile à
dire mais comme le disait virginie il ya
eu de la part de céline ski qui est
extrêmement habile en même temps qu'il
faisait son discours pour dire nous le
battrons jusqu'au bout turc shylia dit
mais en même temps on est prêt à
discuter sur un certain nombre de choses
et il offre ses petites cette soupape
qui est de dire voilà non ok on est prêt
et éventuellement à dire l'ukraine ne va
pas dans l'otan donc il ya quelque chose
il ya évidemment de la part de la russie
personne n'est dans la tête de vladimir
poutine mais on peut quand même imaginer
qu'ils le voient comme un certain nombre
de choses donc manifestement l'offensive
ne se déroule pas comme prévu et il ya
d'une certaine façon une médiation
turque où ils peuvent jouer un rôle ils
sont en bonne position alors c'est un
jeu d'équilibré très subtil mais alors
bon la turquie est membre de l'otan vu
ce qui se passe il ya quand même un vrai
retour vers l'otan exactement comme pour
la hongrie la pologne et autres ou bon
le ya eu beaucoup de guerres entre l'
empire ottoman et la russie s'est quand
même l'ennemi héréditaire là l'idée de
voir tout le littoral
tout une grande partie du littoral nord
de la mer noire sous contrôle russe fait
peur aux turcs les turcs ont joué le jeu
donc ils ont voté la motion contre
condamnant moscou à l'assemblée générale
des nations unies mais ils n'ont pas
pris de sanction en même temps à la
demande des occidentaux ils ont dit que
comme d'appliquer littéralement les
conventions de montreux sur le sur les
détroits le bosphore qui relie la mer
noire à la méditerranée donc plus de
bateaux militaires sauf ceux qui peuvent
prouver que leur port d'attaché tu es en
mer noire ça a été le cas pour un trois
autres ont été bloqués donc là dessus il
ya des choses qui se passent et en même
temps surtout de la turquie est à la
fois extrêmement dépendante de la russie
pour son gaz mais pour le moment par
exemple istanbul seul aéroport par où
sortent les russes en même temps la
turquie donne énormément de matériel
d'ukraine militaire les drones qui ont
mais apparemment ont eu beaucoup de
résultats les back to back yard et b2c
les lectures qui les vendent y en avait
pas beaucoup il en donne d'autres donc
pour toutes ces raisons on peut imaginer
que la turquie puisse jouer un rôle en
plus on peut imaginer aussi de la part
de deux led émir poutine qui comme assez
pervers on l'avait déjà vu ben c'est une
bonne manière d'humilier ces français
qui finalement on sait par emmanuel
macron essayer de faire quelque chose
non pas n'ont réussi à rien finalement
décide de sanctions donc c'est une
manière de diviser pour régner de
montrer surtout ce nouvel ordre du monde
qui est en train de naître on n'oublie
pas que il y avait eu cette espèce de
deux trios
iran russie turquie à astana au
kazakhstan
pendant la guerre en syrie pour des
cessez-le-feu et tout ce qui était une
manière de dire voilà quelque chose de
neuf en train de naître dans le monde on
n'est plus dans le monde d'avant
position singulière de redjep tayyip
erdogan dans entre la turquie et entre
la l'ukraine pardon et la russie les
turcs ont une carte à jouer que d'autres
n'avaient pas jusqu alors virgin hier
alors on sait qu'il ya eu donc vous avez
mentionné les tentatives françaises de
médiation il ya eu aussi des chinois qui
se sont prêt à éventuellement intervenir
israël aussi pour le moment et pas
effectivement laissé les turcs qu'ils
vont réussir à faire cette première
rencontre donc c'est la première fois
que à ce niveau là au niveau des
ministres des affaires étrangères une
rencontre va avoir lieu c'est la
première fois aussi que sergueï lavrov
quitte son pays depuis les sanctions
occidentales donc oui effectivement
c'est une victoire pour le président
turc qui avait dit fin février qu'il
n'abandonnerait nie kiev ni moscou je
cite mais surtout qui ne céderait pas
sur les intérêts de la turquie est
finalement oui effectivement il se
replace au centre du jeu alors est-ce
que ça va aboutir ou pas ça pour
l'instant c'est un peu tôt pour le dire
mais effectivement c'est à antalya
station balnéaire très prisée par les
bus que par les russes parce que ça va
ce parti est le rendez vous c'est demain
h et bien sûr sur france24 merci
virginia merci marc semo d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir on va revoir justement
en images les principaux événements de
cette journée en ukraine